дидатське голосування на відборі
Євробачення яке проходило в дії стало
мабуть таким найбільшим аргументом що не
потрібні вибори смартфоні вони
небезпечні і вони не дозволять людям
вибрати вільно таємно і забезпечити
результат такий як люди проголосували
тому що ми бачили що система не
впоралася навіть з приблизно мільйоном
звернень А уявимо собі що це десятки
мільйонів які захочуть проголосувати
система поставила дуже бага багато
дивних запитань щодо того як зберігати
її цілісність як зберігати її безпеку як
убезпечитися від якихось лівих там
трольвих записів і подібного і все це
мені здається підводить риску під тим що
вибори смартфонів в Україні проводитись
не можуть